the vaccine distribution plan laid out
governor sisalak says now the next step
is really getting back to some sense of
normal
i think a lot of people would agree with
the governor on that brian as kate
houston reports
the southern nevada health district is
now asking the public just to be patient
as they try to vaccinate our entire
community
the kobit 19 vaccine will be distributed
on a tiered approach
and while the general public may not be
vaccinated until spring
health officials say individuals need to
start thinking about it now
when a covid 19 vaccine is approved
essential workers will be first in line
to receive it the southern nevada health
district says the order is determined by
who has the highest risk
and which critical workforces need to be
protected at this time
family members of essential workers will
not be included in the group
the top tier is the hospital workers who
are front line which means
that they are working with coded
patients
or suspect clothing patients directly
and it doesn't include
family quite yet rupert says while the
health district plans to move through
these tears as quickly as possible
she doesn't expect the general public to
be vaccinated until spring
it's going to take some time and people
will need to be patient
it depends on the vaccine uptake
certainly if not everybody wants the
vaccine
we'll be able to move through those
tears really quick and we do plan to do
that
the health district plans to release a
campaign on vaccine hesitancy
which will focus on education and help
individuals weigh the risks of not
getting a vaccine there are many reasons
why
they would or would not but certainly
the health care workers
and those who are front line testing
people
in the lab you know i really would
encourage them to get the vaccine
kate houston 8 news now
now at this point rhu piper says it's
not known
if certain employers are actually going
to make this vaccine mandatory
however some industries such as health
care do require vaccinations for
illnesses such as
measles and other issues like that